hi there see gone from here today first
of all that it's my last video here in
Palm Springs before I go back to
Vancouver I apologize if the microphone
is an ideal we're gonna work on that
when I get home today I want to talk
about why you shouldn't worry about how
well you speak you should worry about
how well you understand that should be
the focus of language turning now
obviously this is my approach other
people may have other goals but in
general I have found that a focus on
comprehension will eventually enable you
to speak
unfortunately language instruction seems
to be focused on getting you to speak
and people are overly concerned about
how well they speak what can I say
various language courses and books
promise you that you'll be able to speak
at some level or other and I have never
found this to be the case if you don't
first have a proper you know base in
terms of comprehension now the reason I
come to these ideas is because I come
across things in Twitter or I speak to
people and we were at a party at our
neighbors the other night and all of
these things remind me of certain things
for example steven crash and tweeted
that all we really need to make sure you
know through elementary school is that
the kids can read properly if they can
read they can acquire knowledge they can
read on geology they can read on history
they can read on any number of subjects
even technical subjects in order to
understand technical subjects you need a
high level of vocabulary and reading
ability this again gets back to the same
concept in in language learning is what
matters is what you can understand if
you understand well some people say well
you know there are people who understand
well but they're afraid to speak they're
intimidated alright if someone is
intimidated is timid is shy about
speaking if they have poor comprehension
they're gonna even be more timid and all
the most intimidating thing to me if I
speaking in a foreign language is not
understanding what
are saying to me yes I would like to
speak better but I can deal with the
fact that I have trouble getting my
words out or remembering them but if I
don't understand what the other person
has said that's out of my control now
that the best I can do is say please
repeat whereas if I'm trying to say
something and I don't quite get it out I
can try again I can make gestures it's
kind of more in my control
not understanding what people are saying
is the worst
once you have good comprehension you can
access books you know movies songs you
can be learning your your snowball is
getting bigger and bigger if you have
good comprehension and I don't believe
that it that you can have good
comprehension and be unable to develop
the ability to speak
some people may speak better than others
fine but in terms of the emphasis of our
learning in my view it should be on
retention not worrying about how I use B
so for example now that I'm committed to
but might be a foolish idea three
languages at the same time our big
Persian and Turkish I am not having any
online discussions with anyone if I have
an hour to spend I'm spending at our
reading and increasing my vocabulary and
my comprehension so I'll show you here
is some snapshots first of all of my
profile in Arabic showing the growth
over time I went through an early period
of intense involvement with Arabic I've
been doing less recently a because I was
spent three months on Persian and three
months in Turkish and I'm dividing my
time up between the three languages but
the bulk of my activity now and
certainly for the next seven or eight
months is simply going to be listening
and reading so you see the profile there
you'll see that I have learned say
roughly 9,000 words of Arabic I have
saved 35,000 by going from memory now
35,000 links so potentially these are
words that I have seen that I have not
yet
now by continuing to read coming across
these yellow words in the text that I'm
reading and listening to slowly I'm
converting more and more of these yellow
words into white words and on my
statistics you'll see that of the 9,000
words that I know seven and a half
thousand were converted in other words I
learned those through my activity at
link if I am studying I don't know
Italian then the fact that both of the
words you learned incidentally because
you can recognize so many words without
ever having to look them up that was
even true in Slavic languages but in
Arabic and Persian there are no free
these are very few so all of them you
learn as the process of coming across
them again and again through these
listening and reading activities I'll
show you a snapshot of an article
actually was a a podcast on economics
from the in France podcast which I had
transcribed and I've studied it and
you'll see that the page now that I've
been through it once and have saved all
the blue words you'll see that there's a
lot of white there and there's a lot of
yellow there that means even though I
believe that I'm you know still I have
so much trouble understanding Arabic in
fact I know a lot more words than I used
to
then I showed you this other snapshot
where I have just brought an article in
from al-jazeera and here there are a lot
more blue words a lot more yellow words
but my goal is to get to where my pages
on link are whiter and whiter with no
bloopers fewer yellow words lighter
yellow whereas showing that the status
of the word has moved up and that would
be an indication that I'm understanding
more and more and so that is my goal now
at this party on the right here at my
place people are talking about the
tremendous burden of student debt that
students require and so I know that in
the u.s. there's this big debate about
free ecologist or not free colleges is
over but when you think of the cost of
university
aah-ha inefficient those institutions
are and that they burden people with
these you know this tremendous debt
burden if people could read well if
people have the initiative they could
learn so much on their own sure some
people may speak better than others some
people may write better than others I'm
talking about in their native language
but I don't very much that if a person
is a very good reader if they read on a
wide variety of subjects if they read up
on the different subjects of their study
at university they read widely if they
need well if they understand well I
don't that they can that they would be
poor writers and speakers much of the
sort of teaching profession in languages
and in English is involved with you know
a teaching critical thinking and asking
questions and all this kind of stuff and
I doubt that that is as effective as
just letting people read and understand
and if their understanding is imperfect
at first such as is the case with my
Arabic I don't want to be answering
questions about what I'm reading in
Arabic I want to read more of it get
exposed to more of it gradually I get
more familiar with the letters I get
more familiar with the words and my
comprehension builds up and on that
basis I will be able to speak one day
I'm absolutely confident of it whereas
trying to teach people to be you know
critical thinkers or to another example
at hi on Twitter I saw this account that
promotes the Catalan language they have
online instruction in Catalan so I go to
the website and what do I find
exercises grammatical explanations by
those dictionaries that's not what's
needed that's not what's needed and so
much of language instruction is
counterproductive why you know in Arabic
I wish there were instead of
me having to go to an automatic
transcription site and to get an
inaccurate transcript of these podcasts
with no punctuation which is difficult
for me why are there not more materials
as was the case in Russia where they
come a suite where you've got the
interview and the transcript
just give us interview and transcript
stories a lot of luck there are many
stories is for beginners or intermediate
people but also just people talking
talking to each other
transcribing is why isn't there just
more great content that we can latch on
to and improve our comprehension and
once we have our comprehension in
learning languages or even in terms of
learning anything at school our ability
to write and to express ourselves will
be better because we have that strong
comprehension yes at that point you can
learn some techniques of rhetoric or
when I was at school in Paris how to
organize your thoughts from your party
does your party whether it had to be
balanced there are different ways of
expressing your thoughts that can be
taught once you have that base of proper
comprehension you know if you want you
can't be a critical thinker if you don't
know the subject so you have to begin
with understanding then some people
might be better at speaking some people
might be worse in speaking it doesn't
matter but I think has learned if you
should push ourselves to drive
comprehension and with regard to
speaking or expressing ourselves I would
say let chips fall where they may
but don't worry about it too much and
certainly when you speak don't worry
about it just go with what you have with
the words you have with your
understanding of something and you'll be
far far ahead
they are alright if you want to get my
10 email a lesson on how to learn
language people click through here and
hopefully we will get to a better
microphone next time around bye for now